non
bonjour et bienvenue sur diagonale
l'actualité internationale du jeu
d'échecs avec stéphane laborde bonjour
stéphane bon jouer moi c'est très chaud
c'est très chaud là on vient de voir la
partie donc cris tchouk kasparov
quand vous invite à revoir puisqu'il est
totalement extraordinaire une partie
d'en faire une partie vraiment
surprenante incroyable donc ils ont fait
deux matches nuls deux matches nuls et
donc y aura des plis se départagent ce
soir entre kasparov et gris tchouk alors
là nous allons maintenant voir la
deuxième demi finale c'est le match
judit polgar contre livni bas relief et
judith laurier repart avec un est andy
kapp puisqu'elle a perdu la première
partie avec les pièces blanches avec les
pièces blanches et que donc barragiste
maintenant aller blanc et donc
il n'eut nul lui suffit il va pas
vraiment pas prendre trop de risques et
il va tenter d'assurer aux besoins de
croiser bas relief stéphane oui il avait
l'air très attentifs et très très
curieux de là comment s'était déroulée
la partie entre kasparov et gris duke
était pendu à tes lèvres quand il lui
expliquer ce qui s'était passé
oui tout à fait très très intéressé mais
surtout il je crois que le truc le plus
important c'est qu'il avait l'air
vraiment détendus
oui il avait l'air assez serein
effectivement souriant détendu et il a
l'air d'être à très confiant pour ça ce
match revanche c'est sur c'est sûr j'ai
vieilli bas relief est confiant il est
tranquille il connaît ses capacités
il sait qu'il joue très bien très solide
et donc il ne perd presque jamais c'est
donc le favori de ce match après le
résultat de la première partie cependant
judith a des ressources et leur
répertoire d'ouvertures qui lui permet
de jouer départ des positions très
incisive y compris avec les pièces
noires oui effectivement elle peut jouer
notamment si barry a ajouté quatre aides
peut jouer estonienne et barrier le jeu
toujours des 4 mai notamment elle avait
joué une belle liste indienne d'ailleurs
dans les premières rondes
si je me rappelle bien oui sans doute
alors je veux plus de quatre parties
tu peux parler dans l'allée jouer ces 5
oui oui c'était contre joël lautier
c'était dans l'élite se départagent
voilà elle a joué une très belle est
indienne c'était une attaque baïonnettes
et on pourrait bien revoir ça ici dans
cette partie bas relief contre paul
guerre alors que beaucoup de
journalistes sont là tous les
journalistes sont très très chaud donc
ils vont venir comme d'habitude il
tourne autour de la scène et voilà judit
polgar qui arrivait avec son sac à dos
sous les applaudissements il va être
très dur pour judith là je suis dit à
risque d'être très très dur on voit pas
trop bas relief il est très solide c'est
sûr d'ailleurs il arrive yevgeny bas
relief
le voilà est ce qu'ils avaient perdu des
parties des qualifications contre
kasparov stéphane il avait perdu contre
kasparov
ça y est ils s'installent d'yves khenin
bas relief contre judit polgar donc on
vous rappelle que si vous avez des
remarques à faire sur le chat est vierge
faites-le nous vous répondrons aux
questions les plus généralistes on peut
pas répondre variante précise puisque il
ya un petit décalage entre l'automne le
temps de la question et la réponse donc
poser vos questions par exemple s'ils
voulaient savoir en savoir plus sur bas
relief sur j'ai dit ou sur la position
en général mais sans variante puisque
c'est un peu compliqué techniquement
voilà nous avons yevgeny bas relief très
concentré il sait qu'il doit faire nul
qui lui suffit de faire nul pour se
qualifier en finale de cette coupe du
monde d'échecs et donc il va tout faire
pour un peu j'ai dit pas garé en face
elle aussi connaît les enjeux stéphane
elle sait qu'elle est obligée de gagner
les oblige il gagne avec les noirs ce
qui est très très difficile
alors que l'arbitré met en route la
pendule ses saillies nous allons tout de
suite allé sur la position à bas relief
a joué ses 4 1 tf6 et c3 où il parle il
joue plutôt langue anglaise voilà ça
sera donc une partie anglaise arias ne
mettra vraisemblance pas d'option en d4
voilà tout de suite d'ailleurs élevé en
d3 affichant tout de suite sa volonté de
lutter contre contre les stars viennent
enfin de ne pas lutter contre ce système
il veut absolument rien dire sauf
illogique de barrières ah oui c'est le
c'était également le choix de gourévitch
il hier quand ils voulaient faire nul
contre son gré tout qui la travaillent
tout et non il n'avait pas réussi par
deux fois il ya eu par deux fois la
russie 2 5 n'ont joué avec eux trois ici
bas relief de rejouer à 3 et voilà c'est
fait au 4e 4 alors ça c'est un coup
responsable stéphane affaiblissement net
a fait briller le net à l'adresse des
quatre ans l'udc avait laissé six plus
tard pourra peut-être revenir sur cette
case des quatre voilà exactement le
cavalier peut envisager devient soir
cette case des 4 pourquoi bien parce
qu'elle ne peut plus être défendu par
les pions les pions ne revenant pas en
arrière et gling ne peuvent pas
redescendre pour venir contrôler la case
des quatre judit polgar a joué décisif
c'est un coût de développement normal
baryal choc cavani géant eux deux et
maintenant on attend soit cassée si ce
soit un coup comme fou aussi ce qui est
également possible
à noter que l'idée de bas relief dans
cette position on voit de l'émission
carrière au dos et pas en rêve 3 ça va
être stéphane de pousser pions f en f4
et éventuellement en f5 voit la
meilleure façon de faire nul c'est quand
même de jouer agressif c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai la meilleure défense est
l'attaqué pour faire nul il faut jouer
pour le gain c'est le meilleur moyen d'y
arriver
quelle joie tirent aucune barailla c6
joué par judit polgar sur quoi paria
froch et là je dis tout à 6 c'est une
très bonne réaction elle veut jouer avec
b 5 commence à mettre la pression sur le
pion c4 ça se joue au niveau de la
structure de pions et on sait que iossif
dorfman connais très très bien ce genre
d'opposition et il dit d'ailleurs que
les blancs doit jouer dynamique
ça veut dire que c'est les blancs qui
doivent chercher tout de suite à
justifier leur choix ils doivent
expliquer pourquoi ils ont placé leurs
pions comme ça
laissant la case les 4
libre d'accès pour les noirs et donc il
faut qu'ils réagissent vite
bara diouf devrait jouer un coup
agressif normalement peut pas se
contenter de jouer des petits coups ici
b4 très curieux ça secoue stéphane on
est très curieux parce que de toute
façon les noirs veut jouer deux des cinq
oui donc se coule n'empêche pas les cinq
espions peut s'avérer faible
alors attention parce que barnier fait
une énorme compréhension des positions
positionnelle justement des positions où
il faut jouer stratégique et donc ce
qu'il joue bekkat ce n'est certainement
pas un hasard mais ça a pas l'air d'être
le meilleur coup à noter la cadence de
jeu qui est rapide
les joueurs jouent vite les georgeault
très vite je dit que le gars que l'on
voit ici à l'écran et bien elle est très
très rapide puisqu'elle n'a fléchi que
de minutes et bas reliefs à lui
réfléchit une minute trente
ça va très vite les joueurs envoie les
coûts ça déroule au rythme dans la
partie stéphane en gorille ça joue assez
vite
effectivement alors que nous sommes
rejoints par bob james fischer robert
robert fontaine champion de france 99
junior et champion de france 2000 junior
aussi les murs bonjour valoir stéphane
alors que penses-tu robert du choix de
bas relief de jouer une anglaise et bah
c'est un choix assez intelligent puisque
lui une nul suffit
et d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'il avait joué
contre etienne donc il ne change pas ses
habitudes ses habitudes qui pour
l'instant gagne oui c'est vrai il avait
joué ça contre etienne pour faire nul
dans la deuxième partie qu'il avait
également remporté avec les pièces
noires alors là bas relief est en train
de réfléchir ça fait plus d'une minute
qui réfléchit donc on se demande ce
qu'il a envie de jouer le dernier coup
de judit polgar n'étant pas vraiment un
coup curieux c'est le couffo aussi ce
donc que veut faire barrière
quels sont les plans dans cette position
c'est toute la question qu'on peut se
poser et robert eh bien oui à mon avis
pour le gars va essayer tout simplement
de jouer fcf 5 c'est à dire enlever le
cavalier hafsi ce soit en et 8 soit en
âge 5 en fait avait elle s'est jouée le
plan de l'east indienne et loire c'est
possible elle peut également envisager
de jouer une coupe 17 b 5
je ne sais pas si tu étais là au stage
de yossef dorfman où il expliqué ce
dessin qu'on analyse en sa partie contre
stephenson je n'y étais pas bien s'il
tordjman et quand même champion de cette
ouverture est dit qu'il faut jouer avec
des 5 pour les noirs et que c'est le
problème
mais bon on va voir j'ai décollé revient
deux fois au cices à noter quand elle
jouera ce fameux coup mais cette baie 5
et bien-être pilonnera le pion c4 c5 et
on peut dire thématiques dans cette
position peut-être que barrière va jouer
à 2 à 4 pour empêcher secoué loi tout
simplement adoré 4 effectivement c'est
une proposition avec l'idée d'ailleurs
de choses des cinq mais c'est difficile
de jouer l'attaqué
côté gauche de l'échiquier pour les
blancs sachant que le pion au cas très
bien et bloque le foot j'ai 2 on dirait
que positionnement est finie baril fait
fausse route
alors qu'on sait que je positionne elle
c'est comme sa spécialité dont l'une
très très curieux à noter que pôle gare
peut aussi par la suite tenté une
rupture au centre par la poussée des six
des cinq noms pour l'instant évidemment
c'est pas possible
mais s'ils y arrivent à jour ça peut
faire très très mal ce coup
effectivement alors ça joue vite la sage
où il ya eu des enchaînements de coups à
le coût proposé par robert est là comme
tu dit robert robert tu as tout compris
qui avait dit ajoutant que j'ai dit aux
gars de jouer avec et 5,7 fois avec f5
très très probable en cette libération
centrale en rupture sur le plus sur le
centre sur le pire - 4 sur la case de 4
et oui alors 1904 pour peut-être
exactement abstract menacera f4 et on
voit mal bas relief réagir en jouant
avec quatre lui même puisque il se
serait quand même très affaiblissant il
commencerait à être affaibli de tous les
côtés oui doit laisser c'est pas
possible tout simplement à cause d'un v6
échec
et oui chorégraphe y ont notamment
baissé ce qui viendrait faire échec au
roi c'est une pure et bouger et qui
prendrait le pion bcap français ont
conscience compliqué parce qu'il ya
tomber un ensuite qui récupérera 7 mai
effectivement fait attention ce genre de
manoeuvre est par ailleurs dos à dos
développer son attaque à l d'âme parce
que pôle gare on voit mal comment on
peut l'empêcher d'attaquer donc il faut
réagir à la dame en jouant bekkat b5 et
pour cela il faut développer le phocéen
pour lier la tour - pour lier un peu
toutes les pièces blanches
le problème de bessengue c'est que après
apprend b5 et bien on peut par contre du
roi puisque la tour 1 serait temps
prises dans l'autre tour donc ici
barailla doit chercher des solutions
soit pour préparer le coût des quatre
des cinq soit pour anticiper la vence
d'edouard en f 5 je dirais que
positionnement c'est judith qui est dans
le vrai lit si elle est dans le vrai
mais brian affectionne ce genre de
position moi je vois bien un coup quand
tu fous c'est un à trois pour essayer de
leur barrage aller jouer à quatre
façades et 5b c'est un cas il le joue
quand même dessin quand même curieux une
surprise d'une vraie surprise dans sa
vie ni celle de centre la part sur fion
premier 5
c'est vrai qu'après le mariage serait
obligé de redescendre du pion c est
décidé simple de suivre
oui où on va laisser la structure nord
comme ça et on contrôle pas mal de cases
au centre c'est très curieuse que fait
barrière très curieux j'ai dit que le
gars va vraisemblablement prendre avec
la piroi on le voit qui jette un oeil à
l'écran géant des pays-bas les daf est
donc ici après b5 et bien on ne voit pas
ce qu'il veut on ne comprend pas on ne
comprend pas son idée à bari doivent
tout simplement
oui on peut comprendre quand même c'est
qu'il va essayer d'ouvrir beldame pour
essayer d'échanger un maximum de pièces
à la lame et ainsi soulager la pression
en tout cas polgar elle elle va attaquer
là le roi session elle peut même le
faire maintenant par f7 f5 le plan le
plan
le plan logique après le coup de
cavaliers en attaque c'est vrai mais
vrai sur l'albret comme prendre abonde
d'abord prendre un bain s'est mis en
fait je suis pas si sûr que c'est bon de
ce soit avant de prendre les loin oui
puisque que mona ce bar yam vraiment
halal dame
eh bien je pense oui effectivement
prises en c6 développerait de cavaliers
de marjah en tout cas il pourrait
reprendre du pied tout simplement
oui c'est sûr donc oui pour l'instant
ils menacent pas grand chose des prix
bas relief mais enfin c'est pas parce
qu'il menace rien qui vaille sûr profité
d'une faute oui nous a probablement
viser contre f5 parce qu'en cas de f5 on
peut prendre entre 5 et le fou j'ai deux
se libère sur la caste et 6 oui et
spoliés par le pion b5 pour faire
pression sur la casse et 6 c'est
possible c'est possible mais ce n'est
pas sûr
ce n'est pas sûr donc dans cette
position je ne sais pas donc on connaît
les plans maintenant on les a tous bien
mentionné le coup fcf 5
c'est une idée pour judit polgar
maintenant la question est ce qu'elle va
prendre en b5 d'abord à la ligne aile
centre et à l'ajout f5 tout de suite l
abri vie il a pris effet d'image 70 des
pions pro f 5 c'est le coût normal dans
cette pression le groupe quasi forcée et
là on peut prendre soit une pièce où
elle à pyongyang prône du pion c'est
plus pour l'attack mais c'est
affaiblissant le roi jeudi le gars est
un peu affaibli à noter qu'on aime bien
sa position que j'ai dit ici
oui tu aimes bien parce que tu as jambes
destin diane c'est vrai cette position
te correspond parfaitement mais maria
flux peut-être préfère sa position on
peut supposer poussé à trois places en
le deuxième fut blanc sur une alors je
pense que d'abord il faut prononcer 6
oui tout à fait pareil à flamatt
évidemment il faut évidemment qu'on se 6
les noirs meubles menace positionnelle
c'était c6 c5 maintenant c'est éliminer
comprendre puis on prend là je me suis
dit où elle peut prendre du cavalier
prendre le cavalier laisserait la case
des cinq très très faible est loin c'est
vrai c'est cette case là quand on
reproduction il n'y a pas de souci on la
protège ce qu'entreprend du cavalier
bien ne la protège pas et oui à noter
que sur pions prend le cavaly b8 aura du
mal à sortir
ça c'est un problème mais est ce qu'il
aura besoin de sortir puisqu'on pourra
après pions prend ses 6 passes et la
tour on a sept puis éventuellement
angers7
après avoir déplacé le fou je pense que
bach haifa a bien joué a bien joué à la
phase qui vient de suivre puisqu'il
ouvre la lame le bébé à la prédiction
ils ouvrent la colonne b pour sa tour
aussi marief il va pouvoir je vais tour
b 1 dans cette causerie info à trois
mois je préfère les blancs c'est vrai
c'est vrai les blancs ont l'air mieux
pourquoi parce que tous les pions de
judith et bien sont un peu faiblard les
pions c6 et définissent et la taxe n'a
pas réellement commencé et la taille de
juni pulga est difficile à décrire mais
peut attaquer avec f4 quand même c'est
un beau coup datacloud 5 et 4 c'est la
menace de judit polgar puisqu'après f4
on menace f3 fourchette
et barrier de jouer à 4 il a prévu dit
il se prémunit contre la menace de judit
polgar à noter que robert qu'est ce qui
se passe sur thur champion et champion
prend pions on suivra tout simplement je
prends pions oui si on propose en option
prend pions c'est un échange
on ne peut pas prendre autrement puisque
le fou g7 se réveille homme avec lequel
ces trois là judith est complètement
dans son élément parce que je dit on
sait qu'à calcule tout très vite elle
qu'elle très bien les variantes
tactiques et bas relief puis oublié
quelque chose dans cette position
puisqu'on voit des possibilités des
chèques sur la grande diagonale qui est
celle là on voit des possibilités avec
le fou g7 sur l'autre diagonale
donc ça fait tout ça un trajet les
possibilités le cannabis et 3 qui est en
prise
la tour 1 qui est aussi en préciser le
roi qui est passera bien placé tout ça
ça fait beaucoup d'éléments pour judit
polgar qui va cogiter dur et oui f4
c'est un coup thématique puisque c'était
le même coup qu'il l'avait employée
contre etienne bacrot dans la seconde
partie il avait réagi exactement de la
même manière donc bas relief sait où il
va la position critique la position est
critique et réfléchir et et julie était
revenue avec son cavalier en rêve 6 elle
recycle son cavalier h5 qui était à la
bande cavaliers vont sur 56 ça y est
c'est joué deux parties dit pôle gare
alors que le club de lutte nous
regardent s'est signalé sur le chat ou à
l'iut
c'est un club peu connu effectivement
miotte donc bah nous les saluons même si
nous ne savons pas où c'est et ils
peuvent peut-être nous en dire plus sur
leur petit club qui est peut être un
grand club d'ailleurs grands clubs
russes vous c'est pas une petite ville
de 50 millions d'habitants comme on en
connaît beaucoup en russie alors
attention ça joue ça joue sajou ou sajoo
ne nous laissons pas distraire tourbe et
un tombé à manas tour baisse est
peut-être un à ce tour d un an
bessette c'est effectivement c'est
l'idée de
bref pour le gars a ramené son client m6
alors qu'elle est qu'elle en était dit
des baisses de cavalaire ashton qui
avait fini son travail
oui il fallait être recyclés pour
contrôler le centre d'accord donc c'est
un combat centrale pour le moment c'est
un combat centrale donc maintenant je
suis dit que le gars est ce qu'elle
envisage de jouer le coup au 5e 4 dans
cette position a priori non c'est pas
possible
donc qu'est-ce qu'elle envisage de jouer
c'est comme problématique si elle a pas
d'idée à napanee judit polgar
n'aurait-elle pas d'idées elle devrait
s'en aller
on peut se poser la question alors
peut-être on va profiter de ce petit
temps mort pour jeter un oeil sur les
joueurs en grand voilà c'est fini
bas reliefs
voilà un plan central avec les deux
joueurs sur la scène du grand auditorium
à cannes c'est les demi finales du
championnat du monde deux parties
rapides d'échec très très gros match et
qui dit bara diouf c'est un russe il est
dans les dix meilleurs mondiaux depuis
des années mais il n'a jamais réussi à
exploser complètement il n'a jamais
réussi à battre les meilleurs il est
donc dans la deuxième chose c'est un
joueur de seconde zone mais du top
niveau évidemment judit polgar c'est la
meilleure joueuse du monde depuis
qu'elle est née pratiquement ont fait en
tout cas on n'a pas souvenir de
l'ancienne joueuse avant elle depuis
qu'elle a 16 ans elle est numéro un
mondial
c'est vraiment très impressionnant donc
ces deux bons joueurs pour une belle
partie on rappelle que ça se joue en
deux manches que la première a été
remportée par l'ilga ni barrières et que
judit polgar doit donc impérativement
gagner impérativement gagner si elle
veut égaliser dans ce match et avait
dans l'épître de départage passer ces
petites précisions vous pouvez nous
faire vos commentaires sur le chat et
vous poser de nouvelles questions
on va revenir sur la top position et
faire un petit bilan pendule il reste 19
minutes à judit polgar 17 minutes 30 à
divulguer ni bas relief donc judith et
mieux au temps li té ni hôtel à jouer
tour à sept et oui c'est prévu
elle s'est prémuni j'ai cherché mon ce
2ème unis quand on tournait cette fin et
cette tour va pouvoir coulisser sur le
7e manger oui c'est un redire en bref
cette par exemple coulissement tout à
fait voire même un coulissage ces sages
de rouen tout à fait et barrière peut
jouer fou c'est un à trois ans menaçant
tout simplement puis on prend 1,5 et un
petit clouage proposition de robert
royal barrière fou c'est un sur la casa
3 qui fera donc une pression sur le plan
des six éventuellement sur la toit fuit
et qui menacera donc directement qui on
prend pion à eux cinq traits la menace
donc voilà le truc fois trois sets un
bon coup effectivement que vivendi
pareil tu pourras jouer
évidemment ils pourront jouer d'autres
il peut jouer le four est roi il peut
jouer et puis on prendra tout de suite
il peut
peut-être même jouer des quatre décades
c'est plus chaud beaucoup de
possibilités pour barrière il va donc a
priori prendre son temps et ça c'est bon
pour judith et oui c'est bon pour j'ai
dit à moi qui regarde évidemment et que
bas reliefs réfléchissent et finissent
par le trouver ce qui ça ne serait pas
bon du tout pour judith a noté kissy la
salle donc et un peu moins remplie que
pour kasparov évidemment kasparov quatre
succès telles affiches du jour
mais quand même le public est une
famille qu'ils avaient encore la fiche
du jour puisqu'il ya le match
départagera 22h entre les deux joueurs
c'est sûr ça va être hyper chaud alors
barnett va je me faut à 3 bienvenue
européen décidément son style
positionnelle s'accordent bien à celui
de bahreïn f puisque tu trouves tous ses
coups pas mal donc la pression la menace
des blancs c'est de prendre avec le pion
24 25 et s'il est noir reprennent eh
bien c'est la tour et suite qui pâtit
puisque le fou pourrait l'apprendre
donc il faut que judith soit liquide en
f4 mai puis on prend avec 4 serait anti
positionnelle puisque bahreïn pourrait
reprendre du cavalier attaquant le faut
et 6 ou alors je retour aux huit
peut-être web
oui ça ça paraît plus logique il faut
grâce au melon ceux des clous et ou
alors bougez lecavalier mais je ne sais
pas moi je pense qu'il va jouer tour au
but je n'invite voici un été que tours
ff7 serait mauvais puisque par ailleurs
fsa devraient attaquer le cavaliere et
huit par dame b3 et ainsi profiter la
colonne mais ça veut dire que il faut
tenir la huitième ranger voilà 2,8 et
manger c'est également important à tenir
la septième et la huitième celle et
orange et qu'il faut absolument tenir
donc là si on se réfère aux critères de
yossi dorfman la structure de pion est
avantageuse pour bas relief varié
puisque je dis tu as des pions faible en
c6 et des six la position du roi est
avantageuse pour barrière le pas et f
puisque il a trois pions devant le roi
alors que gide en a que deux
effectivement et qu'est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres le matériel matériel
elle est égale effectivement judith
arrive à tenir sur le point de terrienne
donc et loi on peut en conclure que
bahreïn est un petit avantage alors que
ça s'est mis à jouer beaucoup plus vite
il ya eu tour 8 de jouer d'amd de
effectivement barrier fait un peu mieux
le tours fc
j'ai dit a remis sa tour en offset et la
barre hayek il s'en fout il dit tour b 2
je dis tu n'as pas d' attaque
tu me fais rien vas-y m'étais pièces
près de trois mois jeudi un plan je vais
jouer touré font bien et je fais tu
attaques et ont payé des huit avec mon
fou g2 qui pilonne champions 7 6 et oui
si pareille fenêtre sur la 7ème ça va
être très dur pour un regard c'est vrai
c'est sur cette position difficile pour
judit polgar il est fort ce bas relief
il est très fort on rappelle quelques
détails sur ce joueur
il ya remporté deux fois de suite le
tournoi de tilburg qui est le plus fort
tournoi à élimination directe le tournoi
de référence ont éliminé cette
élimination directe il a donc les nerfs
solides et ont près stable on peut aussi
dire qu'il est dans une phase de forme
depuis depuis la seconde et crame nico
match comme ni kasparov
il a fait une très bonne prestation à
new delhi et là on le revoit encore en
demi finale de la coupe du monde sommet
rapide ici à cannes
new delhi c'était le champion du monde
deux parties lentes cela fait problème
c'est que l'on voit pas trop quel coup
que je vous lui dites là aussi c'est un
problème ça c'est effectivement un
problème alors que l'ordinateur est en
train de dire
nate avantage pour barrier petit
avantage
oui le problème de paul dire c'est
qu'elle peut pas elle peut pas créer
vraiment de deux menaces là on ne peut
pas créer une rupture au centre puisque
tous ses pions sont fixés par marc et f
donc si elle peut pas créer une rupture
au sens il faudrait qu'à la ctaq avec
ses pièces et c'est pas facile du tout
ce qui est pas facile c'est de bouger
une pièce dans cette position alors on
regarde
les pièces une élue le fou g7 on peut
pas le déplacer la tour eiffe cet a
priori non plus la tour vite non plus le
cas mais ribéry qui peut pas bouger
parce qu'elle tient ses 600 prises
la dame a pas vraiment de cases on sait
pas trop comment j'ai dit tu peux
améliorer la position de ces pièces est
en tout cas ce qu'on sait c'est qu'elle
peut pas améliorer la position de série
alors c'est vraiment judith va pêcher en
eaux troubles
voilà genre h 7 h 5 pour essayer de
faire la de commencer en tout cas là oui
j'aime bien sous couveuse scène
qu'effectivement le courage 5 pour me
jouer h4 et affaiblir le position durant
plan alors que nous avons une
proposition de notre président donc
jacques rosselin homme qui est sur le
chat et qui propose le coup eux 5e 4
pour judith un coup tactique
oui effectivement c'est le possible
c'est ça va dans le sens de l'opposition
on notera que oui mais je dis c'est
possible puisque si les blancs prennent
en quatre
alors on va on va montrer la variante
une spéciale dédicace
notre président bien-aimé e 4 donc il y
aurait facilement pu reprendre 4 mais
qu'est ce qu'il y aurait d'autres et
d'ailleurs je prendrais bien près 1 4
sélections c4 qui est faible il ya pions
s'écartant prise mais le pion des six
aussi est faible ouais mais là on peut
reprendre à leucate tout simplement
voilà mondialisation et c'est à l'option
des six est emprisonné effectivement
robert il faut prendre avec lecavalier
et on voit que ici le fou g7 se réveille
le cadre du kathak la dame attaque aussi
le cas et c'est 3 ces chaussettes
position c'est tout simplement complexe
mais judith ne l'a pas joué je dis tu ne
l'as pas jouer des loyers et ben on lui
dira après la partie on lui dira judit
polgar le coup et 4 allait bien dans le
sens de classe g dames c'est cette fuite
socrates le seul avantage le désavantage
c'est que ça ne menacez rien si on
faisait rien avec le marbre par exemple
tout rêve mais un tout et vous pouvez
jouer des cinq après robert pouvait
jouer des saintes est enfermé ainsi le
fou j'ai deux c'était possible c'était
possible arrêt mcs est joué car j'ai dit
le gars qui ne prend pas de risque en
fait j'en prends pour l'instant pas ses
responsabilités au sérieux puisqu'elle
est obligé de gagner on le rappelle donc
je dis tu parles bien fait peut-être un
peu fausse route
elle se fait masser par bas relief c'est
un massage russe
c'est pas les lois et loi une petite
idée pour barrer pour paul garret veut
jouer damas cet échec et cavalli g41 et
elle ne fait pas forcément fausse route
là la perverse damas cet échec qui
ferait un échec au roi lauro seraient
donc obligés de partir sur les th 1 et
là il y aurait peut-être qu'elle g4 avec
un cavalier qui rentreraient soit 11,3
soit en f2 avec un gros effet c'est donc
un coup tactique de judit polgar oui oui
oui tout à fait tout à fait bien vu elle
commence à faire des petites menaces tu
dit on rappelle qu'il faut pas beaucoup
de pièces pour faire des magasins
elle peut faire de la magie avec pas
grand chose et oui avec rien mais oui
elle a des arguments de ce côté-là judit
polgar elle est très vive être calcul
très vite un rien peut faire balancer la
position c'est sûr ça change rapidement
la position peut se retourner très vite
ouache un bas relief croît chaque si oui
il se prémunit contre l'échec de judith
maintenant si vous lui dites du foot
c'est cette dame à sept sa massette et
bien il pourra jouer peut-être comme h3
je ne sais pas ou alors il pourra voir
venir disons qu'ils gagnent du temps jeu
fois ci ce qui est proposé par
l'ordinateur qui a pas l'air d'être un
mauvais coup dans cette position
stéphane sac lula d'armistice c'est pas
mal ça met de la pression il ya du jeu
peut-être hashtag d'abord peut-être h 5
h 5 c'est un coup qu'on a envie de jouer
effectivement dans ce genre de peu dès
maintenant que le roi et en h1
l'ouverture dans la colonne âge peut
être dangereux pour marié
et oui elle va sûrement jouer h5 judith
elle commence à trouver d'ici là qu elle
commence à trouver des trucs la petite
judith on va voir
bilan pendule 14 minutes chacun égalité
absolue dont pronostiqué loi pour cette
partie pronostique une boucherie non je
ne sais pas c'est une position très
complexe tout tout devient possible
en tout cas c'est vrai qu'on aimerait
bien quand même que judith l'emportent
mais bon y'a fille n'est pas facile à
noter que robert me fait signe qu'il est
pour bright f
oui pourquoi pas cavalli b17 ouhlala je
crois qu'il fait vraiment force contre
la julie c'est un couple bizarre en
curieux on a ce patron historique arrive
ça normalement tour fb un menaçant de
tomber c'est tout simplement mal joué
torbey 8 oui mais changer les pièces
facilite enfin arrange barrière en tout
cas ce qui n'a besoin que l'on a vu que
quand on essayait trop de faire nul
on a vu hier que ça pouvait amener à des
problèmes oui la sas a pas l'air bon ça
n'a pas l'air bon il ya il a joué tous
rêvent d un bas relief évidemment
petit moins qu'avant mena est tombée
celle d'il y menacent d'entrer
complètement dans la position noir mis à
noter que le camélidé ça tu ne peux pas
bouger puisqu'il pourrait suivre tourbe
et six attaquants purs ce 6 c'est vrai
qu'on menace centré sur plusieurs cases
donc ici c'est dur il ya beaucoup de
pression le fou à 3 qui fait pression
aussi je lui dis tu n'as pas trouvé les
mots n'a pas trouvé les coups pour bien
réagir si ici il faut je tombais 8 c'est
pas bon du tout ça se passe très mal
une grosse pression de barrières
conspiration alors est-ce que cavalier
c5 kabylie c'est sain qu'il y a puis on
prend pion aux 5 et c'est fini tout de
suite
l'ordinateur annonce déjà un gros
avantage est comparé dès cet été un coup
un peu qu'est-ce qu'elle a joué les
choix curieux gérer passionnant qu'est
ce qu'elle a fait des cinq thés diack
des six des 5
elle craque elle craque ou en tout cas à
laisser l ess est enflammé un peu la
position n'a la menace positionnelle cd4
la question c'est que se passe-t-il sur
tourbe et 7 et d'autres questions que va
jouer bas relief
alors pourquoi est-ce qu'elle a joués ce
coup des 5 et bien première chose il
fallait faire quelque chose
il fallait faire quelque chose et le
problème c'est que quand la tour venu en
b 7 6 la table repartant des 8 où on
s'est vite et bien le pion des six
auraient été en prise quand il était là
donc déjà elle sauve son pion ça c'est
le premier pont le deuxième point c'est
que c'est une réaction saine au centre
une des idées peut être de jouer soit 2
5 4 qui on fermera le fou j'ai deux soit
des cinq des quatre qui commencera à
chasser le cavalier de ces trois ça
c'est possible aussi beaucoup d'idées
pour judit polgar mais maintenant et
qu'ils laissent ma fille je suis tombé 7
il envoie tour bessette évidemment
posant la question à la dame de judit
polgar où va la dame où tu vas
voilà ce qui lui dit peut-être an à 5 15
à 5 pourquoi pas ça a l'air plus
intéressant que les cases s'est vite ou
des vite que je mets en rouge parce
qu'elles sont pas joli du tout ces cases
elles sont pas joli mais on a noté qu'
un piège sur 2008
il ya un petit piège qu'il faut faire
auquel elle a calé auquel il faut faire
attention c'est fou des six menaçante
retour des 8èmes marcherait pas
malheureusement puisque après qu'est
manip entoure la dame pourrait aller sur
la case de 17 ha oui donc un petit piège
qui n'en est pas un petit viège qui ne
marche pas c'est un piège parce que
justement parlez vous pourrez tomber
dedans en se disant que ça marche il
enfin donc je ne sais pas ce que j'ai
dit elle a dû répondre à la réponse
d'amd vite
le troisième coup d'avion des huit aides
en ont besoin de repasser positionnement
la loi comme plus on croit 5 par exemple
pour laisser la case f4 aux cavaliers
aux camaïeux de will wright il va sans
doute futur proche à 5
bien entendu ça à l'air d'être le bon
coup dans cette position puisque après
quoi la réflexion au sein qui vient le
collier de ressorts soins des quatre
soirs f4 wissous alors prendre un des
cinq puis le 5 mai histoire de soulager
un peu la pression au centre c'est une
autre possibilité
je ne sais pas mais en tout cas ce qui
est sûr c'est que nous allons refaire
notre petit jeu d'évaluation la
structure depuis on est toujours mieux
pour bas relief la position du roi est
toujours meilleur au braille f et le
matériel toujours égale donc évidemment
avantage mariage alors qu'à la pendule
iachini par ailleurs prend un petit peu
de retard il a deux minutes de retard
maintenant il reste 13 minutes et judith
et 11 appareils f donc je lui dis tu
peux espérer l'enfumer henri parriat n'a
pas forcément les nerfs trop solide si
jamais il a plus beaucoup de temps et
bien il peut se faire avoir
we dare la judith qui calcule rennes
micha et avec la reine de l'eshop c'est
vrai c'est comme ça pour l'appel donc
pour l'instant
peut-être c'est l'heure du plan sur les
joueurs un plomb joueurs avec voilà les
deux joueurs qui sont là sur scène 30
auditorium de calmes comme cadre
prestigieux
judit polgar la meilleure joueuse du
monde qui est tout rond et en léopard
aujourd'hui et en face d'elle nous avons
signé bas relief cravate chemise noire
et la coupe des années soixante dix les
beatles et finit par y est très
concentré mais très efficace aussi alors
il joue et minibar hayef nous allons
tout de suite voir ce qu'il se passe je
crois qu'il a pris à vos 5 il a pris un
des singles 5 décembre puis on prend des
5 1 jeudi doivent rassemblant
reproduction c'est et puis on croit 5
sera à suivre et bon avantage mans je
préfère nettement les blancs d'oeufs
puis c'est clair c'est clair que les
plans sont mieux et blanc sont
évidemment mieux mais judith peut
trouver des choses elle a pris du
cavalier en d5 chevally prend des 5
oui ça libère le fou g16 salivaire un
petit peu ce fou maintenant il est
pétrifié devant
et pourtant les devants donc c'est passé
pas si mauvais le coc proposé parle en
attendant sa passion c'est fou des six
stéphanois donc tu avais proposé
je ne sais pas la position est vraiment
complexe ici vraiment très très con mais
je crois que rien ne fait en rien au
fait c'est ça reste compliqué eh oui à
noter que sur wii pour le gars vont
échanger le fou aussi ce tout simplement
après câblée prendrait 5 fu prendrait 5
et échanger le fou g2 qui protège le roi
blanc c'est doit être une de ses idées
elle veut attaquer de toutes façons et
avaient attaqué à la pas le choix c'est
sûr que le meilleur moyen de gagner
c'est quand même d'attaqué est fou des
six jeux par marc hayek vraiment ce bas
relief est quand même en ramenant un bon
joueur il faut bien le dire dit je
comprends très bien ce genre de position
donc la pression est très complexe
je vous le cache pas si vous venez
d'arriver sur des gones al position
extrêmement compliqué on voit bien les
pièces qui s'embrouillent les unes dans
les autres
il ya eu très peu des changes on voit un
foot barrières on se demande ce qu'il
fait là quand même au plein coeur de
l'opposition noir et bien ce qu'il fait
il met de la pression sur le pion aux
cinq de judit polgar en fait lille et
paris a fait 2-1 directement en fait de
libérer ce cavalier o2 libérer la force
potentielle de ces pièces il veut que
judith craquer bouge champions 2-5 et
ensuite son colis pourra ressortir soit
en f4 soit en d4
voilà l'idée de marier avec son pouf ou
des six mais évidemment la pression est
très très compliqué des pièces partout
les pièces vole un peu les pièces vol
oui alors que là bas relief et en grande
réflexion
m
alors que l'on nous fait de grands
gestes tout à fait j'essaie de vous
inciter à parler mais c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile alors c'était fait un a
pas de question sur le tchat
le président il ya une question sur le
chat sommes-nous payée pour faire des
commentaires
question totalement indiscrètes
effectivement qui ne regarde que nous
effectivement on aime bien faire les
commentaires de toute façon voilà j'aime
ce sera la réponse qu'on l'a on donnera
cette question quelles sont mes temps et
loi tant réflexion dix minutes restantes
pour bas relief dix minutes restantes
pour judit polgar et oui ça se tient ça
se tient ça va à noter que si la
position reste compliqué comme ça et qui
a plus que deux minutes par joueur
oula moi j'adore volgare gagnant gagnant
puisque moyen de temps
plus il ya de chances que judith arrive
à trouver des choses et on s'est
compliqué ça allait vraiment redoutable
elle est redoutable et barrail f a
légèrement craqué dans sa deuxième
partie contre bacrot puisque il avait
une finale où il a réussi à faire
annuler facilement mais il a quand même
donné un pion il y avait égalité de
matériel en taille note etienne a réussi
à lui prendre un pion ce qui prouve que
il n'a pas forcément les nerfs aussi
solide que celui que ça oui mais il est
très fort il ya bibard ya fait sa grande
force
évidemment c'est dans les parties
longues plus datant pour réfléchir plus
il peut faire des plans élaborés et
complexe mais dès qu'il faut jouer vite
et que ça se joue un peu
onair justement dès que ça devient très
compliqué qui a des petites combinaisons
à ado francs des combinaisons en deux
coups en beaucoup des trucs très simple
et bien là il n'est plus à 200% bas
relief il ne voit pas tout il oublié
choses et judith peut faire la
différence
à noter que judith là on réfléchit elle
a un peu embêté maintenant il est
clairement nuit hier il a joué damas
cinq la massaye probablement le coup le
plus complexe
proposé par l'ordinateur en tout cas
clouage menace plus on prenait 4 suivi
une attaque triple en c3 ouais ou aux 4
ou 1 4 au choix avec le principe c'est
que le fou g7 va venir attaquer à ces
trois que kay des cinq l'attaquent déjà
et que la dame à 5
l'attak aussi et surtout que lecavalier
ne peut pas bouger puisque la dame des
deux serait perdu tout à fait il ya un
clouage donc d'amazon c'est le bon coup
maintenant alors que l'ordinateur
propose froid au sein qui al'air
aberrant propre aux cavaliers aux quatre
cavaliers ou 4 c'est une façon de se
déploie et stéphane façon peu connu du
grand public mais qui existe quelque 4
ça mais les dames emprise donc on ne
peut pas prendre le cavalier sinon la
dame prendra la dame et si c'est les
noirs qui viennent prendre la dame
blanche est bien le cas ben ali qui
était en plus en 4 revient ça a l'air de
forcer les charges des dames puisque
sinon le coup cavalli g5 serait mort
meurtrier c'est vrai en plus ce qui veut
dire quatre ça a l'air pas mal
voilà ce cookie au niveau 4 sacrifier un
pion à 4 comment ça s'articule en quatre
mais qui avait g5 effectivement revers
comme l'a dit stéphane c'est un coût qui
fait mal très mal
il m'a donné un pion c'est par une
grosse compensation car il ya eu quatre
échanges les dames donc facilite la
tâche de baraf et ce qui va le jouer il
a pas mal de possibilités quand même ici
les pas où j'ai joué alors que ça a joué
sa joie il n'a pas joué samarraï f
il a joué autre chose quelque chose de
très très curieuse si j'en crois ce que
je viens de voir il a joué f-35 judit
polgar a repris du cavalier el-amri avec
le fou il a joué fou prend cavalier est
donc maintenant il ya eu fou qu'on fout
et barriac réfléchi et par agf racolage
est dit est revenu dans la partie là à
sa part est clair stéphane ne l'a pas
donnée c'est fou comme ça à la paire de
fous où elle menace f4 peut-être oui
elle menaçait le cas tout à fait
stéphane pour casser les caves noir
autour du roi blanc
je dis tu vas jouer l'attaqué je vais
l'attaquer maintenant et en plus il ya
toujours ce petit problème pour bas
relief c'est comme le calice et 3 qui
est en crise la dame qui cloue la dame
le cavaly qui attaquent le cavalier le
fou qui attaquent le cavalier et oui et
oui et oui oui à l'arriéré ou là où la
dame chez cinq échecs
alors attention peut-être qu'il a vu une
compétition deux nuls sortie de luis et
du cloud tout simplement
il a peut-être une nulle force un type
qui dit bas relief ton g7 sur la wii est
source et tout g7 qu'est ce qui se passe
sur trop g7 bas il se passe rien
stéphane et six tours j'ai plongé cette
salle je crois que ça perdrait
rapidement après tout reprend tofu
prompt et deuxième tours en 17 tours g7
c'est ce coup non peut-être que le
coucou g7 et plus il faut juste être
permettrait forrester 08 qui est charge
des tours et qui amène une tour sur la
huitième oui oui mais ça c'est pas
forcément si grave non je ne sais pas là
il faut que j'ai dis toi précise
maintenant il faut bien qu'elle
réfléchisse qu'est ce qui se passe
pareil va retourner la situation c'est
maintenant lui qui attaque judit polgar
essais judit polgar qui se retrouvent
mieux sur le long terme autant un bas
relief avant était en train de vie c'est
ses terres il avancé ces pièces petit à
petit sachant qu'il était mieux dans le
temps
maintenant c'est le contraire variable
taux jouer efficacement rapidement alors
que j'ai des pôles car elle joue très
vite justement et je fous g7 et à la
pendule
elle est mieux elle mieux à la 8 minutes
20 et arias n'a plus que sept minutes 40
olalalala ça irait c'est le royaume rail
afghan va jouer très vite aussi il a la
main sur l'échiquier tombe à 8 le coût
de stéphane tout à fait de coûts de
stéphane le coup qui veut attaquer la
huitième manger c'est un bon coup tomber
vite
le cavalier en c3 et en prise mais je
dis tu ne peux pas le prendre parce que
justement c'est pitié branger trop
affaibli et il y aurait donc des dégâts
graves
tours a fait fuiter serait
serait recommandable quant à moi mais je
ne sais pas s'il va jouer puisque sur
touré fait faillite il y un tourin
bessette et oui il fait ma et bahreïn va
trouver une attaque la voie des chances
d'attac pour bas reliefs à noter ici que
l'on voit le roi de bahreïn est
parfaitement sécurisée puisque il
adoption devant lui un fou et
éventuellement catholique pour revenir
alors que le roi de judit polgar et dans
le vent donc toujours cet avantage de
position du roi la structure est on
toujours meilleur pour bright est donc
maintenant le la compensation que j'ai
dit c'est qu'elle a pris la paire de fou
oui il faut que paul gars réussissent à
échanger en a maintenant
après quoi la tâche sera beaucoup plus
facile mais là on voit mal avec sa dame
enceinte comment elle peut revenir
et oui elle est un peu égaré cette dame
là qu est ce qu'apple aurait d'ailleurs
d'avis
sage il était garé est perdu
l'ordinateur propose tout reprend tour
tu en prends tu aurais tout recouvre ce
qui nous donnera donc cela tourteron
tout reprend tours fc est en fuite
on tombe et c'est ensuite mais là
effectivement pas de problème pour
barrier à phil conserverait l'avantagent
donc avantage barise toujours la paire
de fou n'a pas l'air de compenser
pleinement cette initiative de bas
relief la pression sur le roi et
l'avantagent la structure de pions il
est fort bas relief
il est fort maintenant il faut que je
dit lui mettre la pression autant elle
rejoint est fou c'est vite bien joué
elle ne veut pas échangé de pièces
échangées aucune pièce judit polgar à la
raison mais la mariette va prolonger car
ils pointent cavaliers si on prend et
qui aime dire quatre avis se heurterait
à un matt furtif oui peut-être lemattre
en attendant il reste 7 minutes à chacun
ça va s'accélérer maintenant ça chauffe
ça chauffe ça va vite ça va vite
seulement 27e coup oui ça va commencer à
devenir très chaud robert vraiment très
chaud ouais ça va se jouer sur le matin
on attend impatiemment que ça va jouer
sur les nerfs cette fin de partie
c'est ça qu'on aime c'est commencer sur
les nerfs c'est ça qui est beau c'est
tout c'est pour ça que les échecs sont
vraiment un sport à part entière c'est
quand ça se joue aux nerfs alors que
nous avons la partie qui se déroule
tranquillement polgar contre barrière
oui dans quelques minutes ça va
s'accélérer nettement
commencé à chauffer voilà barrière fils
a trouvé un truc il va prendre des
saintes
quel est le point qui le dit c'est il a
joué groupe je lui dit va reprendre avec
l'option tempo c'est fait hélas étapes à
relief car d'enchaîner avec mais il a
échoué qui avaient des cartes non non
non il a joué le coup h3 alors
évidemment c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure sur cavani f4 il y avait
toujours un échec qui posait
éventuellement des problèmes donc parier
que ce prévenu zhu h 30 faisons une
petite caste de fuite pour le roi
petites cases et paul garde va prendre
les cavaliers eu deux puisque évidemment
de le fou s'est vite serait sans défense
et ça ça c'est très grave
donc voilà bas relief toujours mieux
toujours mieux avec hannibal kadhafi il
faudrait que j'ai dit à rennes a activé
sa dame de toute façon elle travaille là
dessus je dit pas il ya un petit coucou
mach 6 et loi serait pas mal pour
demander à dame blanche où aller
exactement
donc c'est très bien qu'elle irait
angers six et l'iran g6 ma ce moment là
les meneurs pour revenir en d2 et ça va
être très intéressant très intéressant
ben oui un petit peu pour replacer la
dame noire sur laquelle des deux a aimé
sa tanière pour la glisse que la case
blanche et contrôlée on propose donc à
ses services pour mettre la dame angers
6 et ensuite venir en d2 et ce n'est ni
un problème le tueur des cinq est en
prise alors alors que le club d'échecs
de le spc inoussa lui eh bien nous les
saluons également évidemment beaucoup de
plats d'un beau coup tu leur fais
beaucoup de clubs
on suppose que les connexions sont
faites dans les clubs ce qui veut dire
que le nombre de gens qui regardent avec
probablement beaucoup sont bien
supérieurs au nombre d'utilisateurs
connectés
évidemment stéphane évidemment donc peu
importe de toute façon l'important c'est
que ce show must go 1 h 6 h 6 damage 5
damages 5 pourquoi on va juste un cas là
ils arrêtent de poule et l'oeuf ou g7
mais en revanche je sais plus le tours
fc est maintenant mariée oui puisque
date ont envie de se re est en prise
avec deux tours sont cloués les deux
tours sans pleurer puisque oui voilà il
ya un big louaj trilatérale et ça c'est
du grand sport la menace de bach y est
maintenant c'est qu'avec des f4 on voit
mal ce que j'ai dit tu peux faire contre
ça et lévis et lé vie celle qui lie
bryant n'a pas lâché sa proie pour
l'instant il reste six minutes à
barillet cinq minutes à judit polgar oui
ici marie-eve gagné 2 0 quelle serait la
première fois de sa serai après
imposition
ouais tout à fait pour l'instant il ya
eu que des seins et demi 1/2 ou un
partout effectivement peut-être que
mariette que gagne 2,0 enfin toute façon
ces bonus ça ne sert à rien
ouais ça ne sert strictement à rien un
et demi ou deux héros c'est pareil ça ne
compte pas pour le classement elo ça car
ça compte pour le classement de parties
rapides
voyez classement de parties rapides qui
pour l'instant n'est pas tout à fait
reconnu puisqu'il ya très peu de classe
et moi ya très peu de classe et on
apprend que les meilleurs aussi qu'il
est numéro un parti rapidement
c'est laurent frayssinet je crois et
c'est à vérifier puisque il a plus de
1800 en parties semi-rapides mois c'est
énorme c'est c'est tout à fait
considérable d'ailleurs c'est surprenant
mais bon il faut voir le classement des
autres joueurs moi je ne connais que
celui de laurent frayssinet cet
emplacement et l'évaluation française
donc pas forcément reconnus par la fidl
enfin peu importe pour l'instant ce qui
nous importe c'est qui va jouer la
finale et ça on le saura après cette
partie
un bilan pendule tour des migrants des
vite faut bien générer des coûts ici
c'est pas forcément facile y prends ta
jeu pur des 5 sur 15 mois me laisser
aller
elle a des clous et la toile cette
poignée le problème c'est que la tour
est surchargé au québec quatre à deux
bras y avait évidemment bas relief
là on voit tout de suite que la plénière
jeudi rang des cinq n'est plus qu'une
ruine las vegas et il faut prendre des 5
c'est vrai et robert il ya beaucoup de
menaces il ya beaucoup de menaces par
ailleurs fils s'amuse dans cette
position énoncée
on a l'impression que judith pour
l'instant elle a joué cinq ans et joue
vite la salle où huit aux petits
intéressant très intéressant autant pour
moi il ya eu une petite cascade et ben
arfa jouait tout reprendre fous ces huit
tours sacrifie et fou prend des 5
voilà la rater ça c'est terminé c'est
fini c'est un coup de massue de yves
bény barailla petite combinaison de marc
hayek qui simplifie maintenant la dame
h5 attaque la toile cette le full attack
aussi et cette fourchette est à venir
elle est clouée est d'alger 6 suis
peut-être d'une perpétuelle puisqu'il
peut se permettre une perpétuelle de son
nez tout avec elle un échec perpétuel il
peut aussi prendre le contre sens et
c'est fini là c'est terminé petite
combinaison hal a raté sa judith c'est
sûr c'est sûr mais sa position était de
toute façon très très difficile à noter
que l'ordinateur annonce ce matin un
avantage d équivalent à 5 pions pour
bahreïn f
c'est donc considérable il lui reste
cinq minutes à barillet fait judith
ayant réfléchi beaucoup pour jouer tour
des mythes la faute
il ne reste que trois minutes mais oui
ce serait bien que bahreïn gagne alors
elle se bat judith quand même un petit
elle se bat elle joue le coup tour à 8
mg 6 échecs cuisants et c'est fini
maintenant effectivement robert après
d'apcher six échecs c'est nul minimum
pour marc aillet fait ça lui suffit au
moins un échec perpétuelle pour bahreïn
f pas sûr il a foulé cette folle mais
mais il faut prendre ça tu es tombé 8 et
man
je crois que il a joué objectivement si
la joie d'alger sinon je suis dit tu vas
jouer foucher 7 évidemment tous gagnent
la fouge et 7,7 au bg aval et h5 par
exemple alors le fou des cinq est en
prise avec échec robert intentions et
oui pas de blague
il peut jouer tour bessette par exemple
fou prend tour il a fait faux bond tour
échec
normalement la tour reprend et
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il fait nul qui
dit bas relief
il ya tour des mythes tout simplement
qu'ils gagnent en ligne touré fuite
après tout reprend tour cavagne aussi
c'est chez qui on prend le fou g7
en tout cas il ne peut plus perdre bas
relief ne peut plus perdre
la question c'est est ce qu'il va
vouloir gagner à tout prix non non il va
et parce qu'on nous donne c'est vraiment
je pense qu'il va prendre la d aller en
finale tourbes et vite et chaque au roi
torah fuite de judith et là que se
passe-t-il tourcoing tours cavalli aussi
sain l'abandon et le juge vite est très
probable on reprend tout on peut se
permettre un échec perpétuerait la loi
iloilo arrive à proposer nul ils jouent
cabinet oc c propose nul 5 revers hayef
et non jeudi choo et je dis tu la joues
elle n'abandonne pas comme ça j'ai dit
paulien nul ça ira ça y est tu es projet
7 et parties nulles s'éteignent la
position finale est loin a noté c'est
fini c'est fini c'est fini il ya
peut-être échappé 10 dh à la fin c'est
donc nulle et voilà moralité facile
victoire de bareilles aviv kenny bas
relief s'est qualifiée s'est qualifié il
jouera en finale le vainqueur de reach
ou contre kasparov qui aura lieu ce soir
à 22h donc si vous avez des questions à
poser sur le tchat
et bien vous pouvez nous les poser
maintenant on y répondra avec plaisir
en attendant nous allons bien vous
détailler le match à venir le prochain
match à venir qui aura lieu stéphane 22
heures oui 22 heures match qui s'annonce
explosif cris tout cas tenu tête à
kasparov de façon très brillante et on a
vu qu'en blitz il était extrêmement
dangereux c'est sûr c'est sûr ça va être
un très très beau match 19h55 en direct
alors que pour l'instant nous attendons
toujours vos éventuelles questions sur
le tchat
puisque nous sommes là pour y répondre
effectivement etc robert fontaine donc
champion de france
2000 chez les juniors stéphane laborde
donc une référence peut-être cinq et
demi sur 6 l'année dernière en nationale
2 donc perf à plus de 2400 je crois wen
belleterre fois et c'est vrai belle perf
et moi même donc et loi rallonge grand
komment grand maître donc nous attendons
vos éventuelles questions alors que pour
l'instant sur la scène et bien il y as
écrite chioukhs et bas reliefs qui se
parle ici de l'air aussi il ya une
réunion de joueurs alors que robert va
nous quitter et bien robert gates en
remercie et je vous rejoins évidemment à
22 ans ce soir pour le match
c'est très simple alors nous demandent
des commentaires sur le match alors
stéphane jeu celui comme une fois sur
celui là eh bien on peut dire que judith
a pas réussi dans la première partie et
son ouverture elle se fait encore une
fois dominé elle a n'a pas réussi avec
les pièces blanches assurent ils
annulent qu'il aurait permis de lutter à
armes égales dans cette partie c'est
vrai c'est vrai donc ça c'est un premier
commentaire bon il faut dire que je dis
donc été éliminé maintenant l euro elle
ne rejouera plus c'est sûr ça c'est vrai
mais c'est la dure loi du système à
élimination directe ce soir qui va être
éliminé kas for food show qu'on ne sait
pas alors qu'est ce qu'on voit dans la
salle stéphane est ce qu'on voit des des
stars ou des
ou dvi p non là je n'en vois pas là tout
à fait on ne voit personne on ne voit
personne
donc on va vous laisser on va vous
laisser sur ce plan final très beaux
plans de la salle qui se vide avec les
deux commentateurs incrusté en plein
milieu donc on vous donne rendez vous ce
soir 21h55 et je vous rejoins tout de
suite en cabine pour le chat
merci de nous avoir suivis